hi everyone I'm Soviet lazy and Maksim
Chmerkovskiy is kissing and telling
revealing details about how he lost his
virginity it's what's trending on 80 now
I know that I was a you know I a late
bloomer for me was 16 and I don't think
that's so late the former Dancing with
the Stars hottie visited the Meredith
Viera show on Tuesday and not only told
his story but also got Meredith to
disclose her own first time well I mean
I was not that young but I was in high
school mine was a supermodel that ended
up lying about her age I swear to God
lying about her age she was about ten
years old and she said and it made her
into like early 30s and it was amazing
max doesn't seem a shamed or embarrassed
about his experience I honestly I think
whatever the situation is as long as
it's wholesome and as long as it's right
you know it's still an experience you
look back and say you know I was an
idiot but it was awesome you know well I
can't believe maxim said such a personal
thing on air but are you surprised by
what he said let me know on Twitter I'm
at some you lazy and be sure to use that
hashtag ET now keep checking back to et
online for more of what's trending